you
[Music]
okay hello everyone today we are very
pleased to have Theo Rocca Gina's here
Theo is an assistant professor at
university of wisconsin-madison
where his work has already won many
awards including a recent Amazon
researcher award today he will be
telling us about using machine learning
for data cleaning thanks Ghia thank you
for coming to the talk and thank you for
having me over so I'll talk to you about
recent work that I have been doing and
my group has been doing on how we can
really follow a different perspective on
analyzing and managing noisy data and
the core idea that we will be using
there is that of statistical learning
I'll call it machine learning for the
sake of being relevant so you all know I
don't have to convince you that more and
more applications rely on analyzing tons
of data like we are in the zettabyte era
now because we want to be able to use
all these amazing AI tools and all these
data hungry applications are very
prevalent but they consume a variety of
different data coming from sensors
coming from IOT devices wearable devices
you know and machine generated data and
logs and well we have to analyze all
this data but there is a cuts there are
errors actually in all of these types
there's errors everywhere so for
instance for sensors we can have noisy
measurements and we can have failures of
these sensors for video and an
unstructured data like natural language
we can have uncertain extractions or we
can have semantics a big Uwe tee for
wearable devices or different connected
vehicles we can have actually adversary
examples so you have noise that is
injected with the purpose of having a
malfunction further down the pipeline so
and of course we have human errors
everywhere especially in machine data
imagine that somebody's pushing code and
they didn't check the commits and now
you have like bugs and errors coming in
right so errors are everywhere and in
fact I will claim that error
and low-quality data is actually the
Achilles heel of modern analytics and
this has been observed by many analyses
for instance this graph here so that
actually domain experts and analysts
they spend 60% of their times as
collecting and I'm cleaning up data to
be used in downstream analytics and AI
projects designing machine learning
models and designing analytical models
is becoming more and more streamlined
with libraries like tensor flow pie
tours or even more recent results like
Ludvig from from uber it's just
drag-and-drop right so there are many
modern systems that have appeared in the
database and data management research
that try to address exactly this problem
of low quality so you know you have
academic systems like whole Oakland
which I'll talk about today and snorkel
from Stanford Google has this data
validation library for tensorflow
amazon has DQ that is again monitoring
system basically for data quality
problems in ml pipelines so there's a
lot of work around this area of develop
systems that can safeguard basically
your pipelines against low quality and
erroneous data however in my work I want
to answer as a as an academic I want to
answer a simple question which is
fundamental which is what is an
appropriate and formal framework for
managing noisy data and I will put two
constraints here one is that I want a
very simple framework and I want a
framework that can generalize the bunch
of different problems in analyzing data
quality so what I'm going to talk to you
about today is a little bit I'm gonna
start with some background on what noise
means what what are the types of errors
what are the types of quality problems
that one observes in real world data and
what how people have tried to address
these problems in the past and then I'm
going to introduce actually the core the
theory core or
all the systems that I have been
building the last few years which is
this probabilistic and clean databases
framework and then I'm going to show you
how you can actually rely on this
theoretical framework to build useful
systems for a bunch of data quality
problems so let's start with the first
part by the way feel free to interrupt
me at any point if you have questions
let's let's make it interactive so what
is noise in data so let's start with
this simple example this is a snippet
from a data set from the released by the
city of Chicago it has to do with
inspections of restaurants and you can
see a bunch of different problems so DBA
name was supposed to be a key but now
you have a different value for the same
restaurant you have typos about the city
you have different conflicting zip codes
for the same establishment and in
general these data sets sometimes they
don't come alone but you may have
constraints that try to describe what
should the correct instance look like
right integrity constraints like
functional dependencies so you have a
variety of different problems in real
life data and the computational problems
you want to solve given such a noisy
input and potentially a collection of
domain knowledge constraints is how do I
identify errors in this data set how do
I fix these errors and basically how do
I do in this scenario for for database
people consistent query answering over
this data set or for machine learning
researchers robust machine learning
models hardlight do this thing these are
the types of computational problems so
people have actually in the database
community people have studied this
problem and in fact even the very first
paper by code was talking about how do
we handle null values right so we wanted
to safeguard against inconsistencies in
our data and in this case for instance
if I have this unclean database and my
integrity constraints I can talk not
necessarily about erroneous data but
inconsistencies so the errors here
correspond to either tuples or cells
that basically introduce instances that
violate the
constraints and these types of
inconsistencies are very typical in data
integration scenarios in ETL workloads
where I'm extracting information from
different sources and I'm trying to
canonicalize everything right and people
have proposed that to address these
problems people have proposed this
framework of data repairs so it's a
theoretical framework that tells us how
to cope with this inconsistent databases
and the target computational problem
with these people wanted to solve is
that of consistent query answer for
instance if I want to find all the
distinct cities from this snippet I
should only get Chicago not Chicago ok
so the tool that allows people to deal
with these types of inconsistencies was
to define a different database that of a
clean version of the noisy instance that
you have and that would be the repaired
database and this is a slide from
actually an authority in the space of
data repairs and the way you wanted to
solve this problem is to find an
instance that has think of it as like
the minimum added distance were added
here is in quotes because there are
different definitions of edit the
minimum distance from that initial
instance that you saw so you want to
basically perform the minimum number of
transformations in your data set and get
a consistent version and you can now try
to see can I answer queries on that
consistent version and there are a bunch
of different types of these types of
repairs but and a bunch of theoretical
results here that all have to do with
tractability
and repairs of repair taking and can I
do consistent query answer and given
different types of definitions of
repairs and so on and so forth
but I don't have to convince you that
none of these things actually made it in
any product and are not really used in
in practice very limited adoption and
the reason why there is limited adoption
let me convince you with an example if I
have this data set you see that I have a
bunch of errors I have knowledge about
my constraints I can actually convert
this data set into
what we would call a consistent data set
by deleting the first Tuttle now this is
a repair database I don't have any
violations of these constraints under
the the FD that I have however what I
just did here is to remove the correct
tupple and not only that I actually have
errors that persist these two errors the
type of the obvious typo is not fixed
just by enforcing the integrity of these
constraints and I actually went and you
know I have non-obvious errors this 6:09
is actually the wrong zip code and now
my integrity constraints are not
powerful enough to capture that fact so
and I can use different variations of
this type of repair but all of them will
actually have similar problems so people
try to address this by going away from
minimality into that or the land of
statistics
so they started thinking of okay let's
think of these tuples as noisy
observations of what the real tuples
should be and associate a probability
with each of these tuples for instance
the first one is correct true with a
probability 0.9 the third one with 0.4
and the last one with 0.8 and so on and
so forth and then the goal there is to
actually find the most probable world
given that I want to have to enforce
this integrity with respect to my
constraints so it becomes an inference
problem that I want to solve from a
practical so you know in this case the
optimization objective is I can now
given that I have the constraints I can
start removing tuples or performing
different edits in my day I said to find
basically to maximize the likelihood of
these tuples and there are different
ways that you can do that the problem
the big fundamental problem here from a
practical perspective is how on earth do
I know these probabilities to be able to
reason about this world right so it
becomes a learning problem now that I
don't have access to these probabilities
it's semantics we the probability should
be like the probability that it is
correct
so in this framework it is the
probability that is correct in our
framework we can give you we will talk
about the distribution over the exact
values and in fact I will show you how
you can you don't even need any training
data you can learn these probabilities
you can reason about these probabilities
just given these as input so in our work
we're trying to come up again with a
theoretical framework that can give you
guarantees on the output of any
algorithm that we will design to deal
with noise and we want to be able we
remember our requirement has to be
practical and I'll show you why our
process is practical so we follow a very
simple approach that has been actually
very powerful in the bunch of other
techniques that of a noisy Channel how
many of you know that noisy Channel
model on the better so what is the noisy
channel model the noisy channel model
assumes that you have a clean version of
your world like and then it goes through
a process that introduces errors and all
your observe is basically the erroneous
version the unclean version this is a
new your goal now becomes given that I
observe that noisy version I want to
just find the correct world the most
probable correct world applications of
this is every time you actually type
something in your phone or your laptop
and you make a mistake a typo and the
spell checker fixes that it's an
application of this model so spelling
correction part of speech tagging
machine translation all these are NLP
applications where actually this noisy
channel model is the framework in the
theoretical framework become behind
having all these practical applications
so motivated by this we developed a
framework that relies on this idea of a
noisy channel for data cleaning for
managing and repairing and cleaning
noisy data so what is our framework
we start with a clean data source and we
assume it goes through this noisy
Channel and we observe our errors
because it's a product we want to design
a probabilistic framework to understand
to really capture inherently and model
inherently that the notion of noise
probabilities give you that is the right
tool here so what we assume is that we
have some generating process is a random
process that gives us a clean version of
our data you can think of it as you know
the randomness is the fact that
Starbucks appeared in a specific corner
of the street and not not another corner
right that's the real-world process that
is happening you have what we call a
noise generator we will refer to it as
the réaliser this is our noisy Channel
this is again a robust a random process
that injects errors and what you observe
is just this process operates over a
sample of your initial process and what
you get back is a final dirty database
so given this description you can now
start instantiating these two
distributions basically so one is a
conditional distribution this is a
generating distribution you can
instantiate these two to reason about
what is happening in the dirty database
that you are observing so for instance
if I want to model how correct data
should be generated I can do that by
enforcing a certain probability over my
row correct doubles and then I can also
have another component that tries to
capture exactly the fact that integrity
constraints should hold in the clean
version integrity constraints are not
and while they have been used as an
artifice as a tool to find errors they
should actually hold in the clean
version right so it's kind of a logical
a bias towards consistency and for my
noisy Channel I assume as I mentioned a
conditional probability distribution
that operates over a clean instance of a
database
and then what we really have is a
distribution of other possible swaps
just to give you some examples of errors
that you can capture using this these
models by putting these things together
for instance if you want to capture
duplicates so my clean version was this
and now I want to model how duplicates
are generated the orange part here tells
me basically together with the green
tells me that the probability that an
adversary will add the clean tuples is
separate from the probability that I
will actually go on add an artificial
couple the red one up there that was not
in my real world so we can model the
generation of duplicate data at the same
time we can also model errors due to
transformations so what this in this
scenario if I have a type of formalism
or the wrong zip code all I'm saying is
that I took the original clean data set
and I multiplied with a probability that
I will swap the two values for something
else what this does effectively is that
it separates the cause of errors from
basically how these errors chains
features in the underlying data
distribution and I'll show you what are
the interesting problems that you can
answer now where this frame so think of
it as basically have the distribution
that generates the correct data and I
just pass that through a conditional
distribution that generates my errors so
we want to split these two so what are
the problems here the first one is first
of all what is the input the input we
will only have the noisy data we assume
no information about these two
distributions at all which is practical
because in real life all you have
disaster dirty data set the first
problem is to say okay if I knew
anything about these two distributions
so imagine I will I will talk about
learning them but if I knew them can I
actually correct the errors if I know
the process in which data correct data
is generated and which errors are
introduced can I change
I fix that noisy instance day and I'm
observing so I want basically to find
the most probable instance I that given
these two distributions would actually
give me what I am seeing
that's the first computational problem
the second computational problem is I
want to answer queries directly on the
noisy data set and get answers with
guarantees as if I had actually asked
these queries over the clean database
and the most interesting problem is okay
can actually learn these without any
training data and I want to just use day
to learn basically these two
distributions notice that if we have
access to this we basically build we
have built this spell checker that is
running on your phone for NLP we have
done exactly the same thing for your
relational data number two is that noise
is bounded
hence what you are observing and I will
talk about that hence what you're
observing in your final version we
talked a bit about it it has redundancy
and bounded the amount of noise
therefore you can actually recover what
is the correct value for the different
values in your data think of it the
equivalent would be in robust statistics
instead of taking the mean I would take
the media so now I don't need to go and
clean my data set I will just take a
minute and comes with certain guarantees
given a certain type of noise it's
similar to that okay so this is
basically the framework that that a
theoretical framework that we introduced
last year to describe what cleaning
really means motivated by the noisy
Channel and motivated by applications
from like the Chicago in the Chicago
data said you would see zip codes being
wrong it wasn't the type of the the real
reason why it was wrong actually if you
were to dig into the in the data it
would be that it was actually right on
the boundary of two zip codes and
instead of this is 6 0 9 6 0 8 it's
actually because it's right on
the boundary these are data this is data
that that was manually collected by
inspectors and probably the inspector
didn't know that you know they switched
boundaries so these would be the form of
the réaliser okay so given these
problems we have a bunch of theoretical
results I'll just go over them quickly
the first one is that we saw that
whatever people have done in the past in
terms of theory it's actually subsumed
by this model
so all these got Milly morality repairs
they can actually be explained as
specific instances of our framework so
this framework is more general we can
capture these notions of added distance
that I want to update the minimum number
of tuples or I want to edit the minimum
number of cells in my database and the
most interesting one is that actually
sewing when doing when cleaning is
efficient so in in as you would expect
you know in most cases we want to run
inference right so that's a very
expensive process however we saw
recently that you can actually get
guarantees that would give you exactly
the information theoretic optimal result
would be the result of exact inference
over this framework and you can get that
actually with approximation algorithms
so let me talk a little bit about these
results and then I'll move on to two
systems so the set up here that if I if
I'm too abstract cleaning completely and
put it in in a formal framework I can
view it as the following problem of
statistical recover imagine that you
have a graph and you know the different
nodes should have certain labels and the
edges capture interactions between these
nodes and you have a bunch of labels for
the different nodes and but you don't
know the actual correct labels what
you're observing is some noisy
assignment to the different nodes and
you're observing also parity constraints
from on the edges and even these parity
constraints can be wrong so just an
example
the nodes here in a data set can
correspond to cells and the value that I
see is the label the parity edges are
basically information coming from
constraints right that constraints could
hold approximately so our goal which is
exactly the same goal as data cleaning
is I want to recover the correct
labeling for each of these nodes so
formally what you want is you want an
algorithm that will find this
approximate labeling this estimate X hat
that will minimize your expected the
worst-case expected hamming error I
expect it because you don't know how no
is is being injected right I don't know
how at the adversary or the noise it's
an Elise flipping these labels but
overall these possible noisy channels
that I have so we're all over the
different assumptions that I have for my
noise I want to minimize the error
basically between what I'm gonna get out
of my algorithm and what the clean
unknown noise was so this is a standard
problem in fear it's called that of
statistical recovery there are results
that demonstrate that the optimal thing
to do here is treat this as a
probabilistic model run inference
marginal inference over each individual
node and take basically the mode of that
distribution the problem here is that
actually this is a computationally
expensive process I cannot run inference
so people have proposed approximation
algorithms for the binary case what we
saw is that actually you can get
guarantees even if you have categorical
labels so now imagine means in your
cells in the database
you know the domain of an attribute like
zip codes or series these are
categorical variables and if I have an
algorithm that can give me guarantees
for the previous problem in the space of
categorical variables I actually have an
algorithm with
formal theoretical guarantees for data
clink so what we sowed is that you can
actually get an algorithm that is
efficient it did it's an approximate
approximation algorithm because you
cannot really get information theoretic
Optima but it comes with current ease
depending on how many labels I have K
basically for my categorical random
variables and what is the density
they're basically the structure of the
dependencies I have so forth three we
saw that arise and what our algorithm
actually proceeds as follows it's
something very interesting and simple
you decompose an input into connected
basically regions and then you perform
correlation clustering to find groups
that should have the same value and you
assign that value to all the nodes
within that group and then you do
afterwards one check to make sure that
you have consistency across across
groups so it can relies on on clustering
based correlation clustering results the
interesting thing is that this algorithm
gives you guarantees as to P here is the
probability of error that you have and
you can saw that the lower this
probability is and the lower your domain
is the better the guarantees for your
algorithm the interesting thing to
notice for the general case is that
actually the more noise I have if I have
a dense structure actually lots of
redundancy in my data this noise part
will go down so it it drops
significantly so in terms of statistical
guarantees I am much better having lots
of redundancy in structuring my data and
lots of constraints the problem is that
in that case actually I can only do it
for low tree with graphs I can only get
these results for when when I have
bounded structure so you have these
types of trade-offs that coming from
statistics and for computational
efficiency but overall what our
framework is giving you what these
results is that
given a bunch of categorical labels
I need bounded noise I need noise that
should be bounded by this quantity to be
able to recover if I have more than that
noise actually any automated solution
will fail which is a powerful dichotomy
to know because now you can actually
detect in many cases if any automated
cleaning tool will actually work or you
actually need to involve the humans in
the loop and will be the number of cells
K is how many labels I have for the
different the category the categories
that I have and P is the probability
there of noise and having errors best
says am i different than my the size so
now really this result tells you that
okay if I have lot of domains in that
table so think of it as I have super
high entropy in a column and I don't
have any constraints I cannot do
anything no automated the cleaning tool
even if I use machine learning even if I
use anything won't work I need a human
to look at it on the other hand if I
have a small domain and lots of
repetition I can actually fix it in an
automated way and I can get a formal
guarantee of that so all of our systems
are basically designed around this
dichotomy any questions on that
okay one more heretical parenthesis and
then to the systems we saw actually here
that that's an interesting result that
we saw that in many cases if you have
now this type of bounded noise I want to
know this P I want to know all these
statistical properties of my dataset you
can actually learn them even without
training examples as long as the type of
noise adversary and the amount of noise
injected by the adversary is bounded so
I enabled up to you know epsilon errors
in my data set epsilon percent of errors
so it's kind of a knob that says from
all these cells in my data set if thirty
percent is corrupted then I can
potentially learn the correct model
directly without having any labeled data
okay so you can use this basically this
result together with the inference
results just to describe the types of
guarantees that the models obtain okay
so how do we use this this framework in
practice and what are the systems that
that we have built around this idea of
when can we perform automated cleaning
versus when we can we really need to
bring humans in the loop
the very first system that we built that
in fact the system that initiated this
entire line of work is hollow clean so
hollow clean is the first practical
probabilistic data repairing engine and
until now it's kind its state-of-the-art
at least the new version that we have
that we have improved our results but
really that our first exploration was
just trying to basically find model they
intention part of this noisy channel
model which was how do i generate my
clean data forget my noise I know that
certain things are wrong so I don't care
now about how noise was injected because
I you have told me this is actually a
wrong value I want to learn the
distribution of how the clean data is
generated so that I go and basically fix
it fixing here is I can treat it as
empty and I can impute it right
so what we do in in Halloween we casted
this problem as inference over a
structured model a factor graph a factor
graph is basically nothing more than
saying that each of these cells is a
variable for which I need to make a
decision what is the correct value and
all I need to do is use my integrity
constraints and other properties of the
data set to enforce an alignment across
these different values so I want to
enforce a joint state for all these
different random variables so in this
case for instance I can have constraints
like c1 here that corresponds to a zip
code to determine the city which couples
the fields of two tuples that they
should be in agreement with respect to
this constraint or in other cases I
could I should respect the natural
co-occurrences that are happening in the
data set I should never go and suggest
winds constant as the state of Chicago
because I never saw that co-occurrence
happening in the data okay so this
complex model actually so these models
really how the clean data generate data
generating distribution so the
generating distribution for the clean
data how it should be modeled and then
all we need to do is run inference over
that we cannot it's it's it's expensive
right it's a start it's our p-complete
to actually get yet this inference so
back back then we did a bunch of
approximation tricks to be able to
perform inference by pruning large
domains so we wanted to minimize that K
that I showed you and we also wanted to
relax these constraints to have
relational features turns out that
actually both of these options are very
well explained by what we our
theoretical analysis tells us now so the
most interesting thing in Halloween was
basically how do we make these
constraints this thing scale and again
we relied on this notion of bounded
noise so if I have bounded noise and I
want to enforce these joint state in my
world
I don't have to go and enumerate all
possible worlds and check their validity
I can rely on the fact that the initial
world that I have seen is somewhat close
to the state that I'm looking for and
what you can do using this intuition is
that you can break these complex
constraints so the constraint that
creates problems is this one because
think of a functional dependency I want
to enforce it over or any pair of tuples
I will actually have this kind of
structure being instantiated for all
pairs of tuples that I have in my data
set it's a complete graph and I'm
basically dead so how do I break this
remember I assume that the initial table
is the correct one and I just convert
these global constraints to local
constraints so I will assume that
basically the assignment for the city
for tableau one should actually not
violate the assignment of another tuple
the actual initial value of that other
tableau so in aggregate you can see that
if I start the numerating over all the
tuples that I have in my data set what
you see there is that if I have bounded
noise most of these features most of
these assignments will actually have the
correct value and I will be able to
enforce this type of constraint in a
noisy way
however breaking these constraints and
having these relaxed factors and I can
do this in with different weights and
different parameters for the different
directions of the constraint right I can
do it for the zip code so that it I want
zip codes that are compatible with
whatever I have seen in my initial said
I want cities that are compatible with
whatever zip codes I had seen in my
initial set and given that I may have
different noise levels at different
attributes I actually have different
weights for this model so this is the
relaxed type of model that we're
learning in reality this corresponds to
logistic regression model with an
interesting coupling of the weights so
it's very fast and back
it would act yeah yes so what is it
about the probabilities here that would
suggest that I shouldn't just change the
address of T one two three four six six
South Morgan Street or you know
something else that would actually make
the zip code okay so really they're the
different currencies that you have with
the I skip the DBA name and other fields
here if you remember the original set
had keys and other things so it's these
types of dependencies that tell you that
this street address actually corresponds
to that key and so we're just wondering
how many degrees of freedom there are in
practice in these in these cases and
whether you've got a knot with whether
you've got enough information from the
probability distribution to steer you to
so that's what right answer remember
this so it depends on the structure if I
don't have any structure all the
attributes are independent I cannot use
that context to to fix anything the best
thing I can tell you is take the most
frequent value or take the median or the
main the question is that we want to
build systems that will tell you that
without going and performing cleaning at
all we immediately you'll see that
profile and then given that you have
enough structure and enough constraints
to not have so many degrees of freedom
then you want to perform automated
cleaning so that structure is words it's
otherwise correlations of columns or
what week it's not just it's not it
first of all functional dependencies are
a little weird because in real databases
they they almost hold but not quite and
so even using it as a constraint can be
problem that I agree and then but what
you often do have are a lot of attribute
correlations which are are you a drafter
if you bear with me until towards the
end of the time I will show you exactly
what house guests
that we want it's basically the
structure is think of deterministic
structures that would tell me attribute
the address is kind of a function a
deterministic function of these other
combination of columns if I can if I
have this type of structure I don't need
to learn the axial function but now I
can use machine learning to find that
mapping so we want this deterministic
they're not causal structures but they
relate to structured structural models
basically and now I'll show you exactly
how we can find these structures later
in the talk so yeah so hollow clean
worked the interesting thing for us here
is that actually back then we were using
a probabilistic inference engine so okay
it runs faster but the interesting thing
is that was actually more accurate than
running deep sampling on the full graph
which makes sense because Gibbs sampling
wouldn't necessarily converts to the
correct solution but having this relaxed
model and under the assumption of
bounded noise you actually get the
correct distribution maybe you could
kind of use some learning to say that I
will build it only for the top five
sinkholes that are more probable
according to this model so this is kind
of yeah we were using so we would do
very nice filtering conditions based on
knife base to prune basically the most
Pro find the most probable values and
then we would build the factor graph
over these values this is with pruning
so these are both with with curry the
problem here sorry the problem there is
that really these the functional
dependencies style of of constraint they
lead to a model that for which
approximate inference really want
convert it needs an exponential number
of steps and if it gets to a
minimum there is no way of turning back
also I should tell you that we don't use
these models anymore we have moved away
from these two like actual very
interesting deep learning models that I
can I can talk about them offline and
that rely on a torn attention and
learning that structure on the fly
okay so that was learning the
distribution HoloCam used to learn wants
to learn the distribution of the clean
data we have this other system called
hollow detect for detecting errors that
again focuses on learning the noisy
Channel so we will learn a separate part
of the distri of this pud model now so
the whole idea there is I want to learn
this realizer
but that really learning that réaliser
if I want to teach it I'll take the most
interesting network out there deep
neural network I need a lot of training
examples the reason what so the question
they are fundamental is how do I find
training data to even learn this
distribution again we will rely on this
notion of bounded noise and our approach
what it does is thinking of error
detection as a binary classification
problem for which we have lots of
heterogeneity and imbalance and we want
to generate training data what we do is
we treat we analyze the input data set
and we will learn a very simple model
through program synthesis as to how
errors are injected we will rely on some
annotations from the user a very small
number of annotations for instance here
the user would say you know what Fort
Apple 3 it shouldn't be Chicago Illinois
that's 60 the correct value for City it
was actually Chicago alone so we use
this information labels from the user
remember that condition a very small
number of labels learn how learn
transformations as to how noise is
introduced how does this noisy channel
introduce errors for instance in this
case I can add the character to inject
the typo I can remove a character I can
exchange full sequences of characters
and we use this know
it's an all that we have learned to
perform what is called an ml data
augmentation so we would take these
initial training sets together with data
tuples from our original data set then
go and introduce new examples for
instance we would say here is an example
of an error I can go and flip the
business ID from porter - EVP coffee
that's a full exchange so I applied this
transformation for the second one for
the city I left it the same so I had
Chicago I made it sorry I introduced
another error sorry
now that example is just a lot of humans
so the inspector was probably Italian so
that that's the approaches used program
synthesis to learn these small errors
and and then train a model these are
some example transformations that we've
learned from real data so this this is
actually a benchmark data set where you
have typos being injected by a by adding
the character X you see that the most
prominent transformation it learns is X
I should changing everything to X this
is from the adult data set in UCI where
that it has some naturally-occurring
errors it learns that you actually may
in many cases people mix female with me
so the most prominent transformation is
flipping these two values and this was a
data set proprietary actually this is a
desert from Berkeley about animals and
they have this column that talks about
basically the animals in captivity that
can take values ro or empty and there is
confusion between R and M T and R no so
these transformations are learned
directly from the input data set and
some examples from humans those
transformations
because a lot of these at like typo
generation which is which home probably
true or cause some antennas and said
flipping values for the same domain is
also a common so so this doesn't require
that you're in the same domain this is
the most general transformation says it
restricts you in the sense that I want
to flip the entire string so go and
learn the sweets without asking users to
provide a small set of labels for that
specific UI so in the paper we actually
have results where we saw that you can
obtain these from using unsupervised
methods and then take only the high gear
confident attributes
sorry assignments off of the network and
use these as examples and then run
program synthesis and undo so we have
these we have experiments in the in the
paper that solder what you are
restricting here a lot is you're
restricting your noisy channel model to
only introduce these types of errors
this last one is quite generic though
like in this case it learned that I can
flip from the same domain it could be
that we didn't restrict it to be in the
same domain system and dessert and then
you train a machine learning model that
takes into account a bunch of different
statistical properties of the data set
that have to do with the attribute level
representation of your data top-level
data set level to just answer that
binary classification problem is this
cell value wrong or correct so is it
compatible with the distribution I'm
learning or not and what we find which
is interesting is that actually our
approach is much better than active
learning so active learning because of
the heterogeneity that that you have in
your data set requires a lot of training
examples to be able to pick up this
information and in fact it gets stuck as
well however doing this type of data
augmentation strategy even with a small
number of examples works very well in
practice so and on average what we
observed across the datasets that we run
experiment with is a three times 3x
reduction in terms of the training they
thought you needed with respect to
active learning which makes this way
more practical like for some datasets
that the noisy Channel itself had
repetition in terms of how errors were
injected specific typos imagine you join
two tables and you have repetition and
the typos and so on then actually with
just a few examples you pick it up right
away so that reveals the power of
program synthesis for learning
transformations in that field and it's
an interesting area that we are
exploring further here now coming back
to Phil's question about structure I
will still call them functional
dependencies but I will use the correct
definition of functional dependency I
don't want dependencies that hold in the
instance so I don't want any
syntactically correct function of
dependency but I want to find
dependencies that holding the data
generating distribution so I want cases
where for instance they say some of
these scenarios here they say that you
know the zip code is really determined
by my address and my hospital name in
this scenario or for this specific data
set actually there is this where is it
it's actually pruned there is a column
called state average where this is a
concatenation between measure and to
other columns so that is an explicit
function if I merge these two I will get
the last one so now I can fix errors
just by following that function so we
want to find we cast this problem of
functional dependency as that of
learning the structure behind that
distribution where the structure is
limited to learning these types of
projections so it's actually a linear
model think of an auto regressive model
these attributes should that tell me
mystically dictate the value of another
attribute and we have an approach that
relies on robust again robust statistics
or bus covariance estimation by taking
samples pair routes of tuples sampling
pairs of tuples over the data set and
computing differences and under again a
weak réaliser weak here means that the
and the amount of errors is bounded you
can actually so that you will get the
correct covariance and from the correct
covariance you can actually get this
type of structures so what these
structures this is like two data sets
from from UCI so the interesting thing
for these trucks or RAL result is that
you can do a bunch of things now for
automating data prep for instance I
don't need to run any machine learning
model to do feature engineering these
are to UCI data so this is an obfuscated
data set about credit approval and the
target attribute for classification is
like a 15 I don't know what it means but
there are a bunch of papers that
actually say that the most important one
is a eight across a bunch of different
data set so with the machine learning
models all of them should be finding a
eight as the most important one for
classifying so we actually find that by
running this very cheap model this runs
extremely fast so it's this very cheap
models will tell you a eight should
determine a fifteen the way to interpret
this is a fifteen is equal to some
function whose input is a eight I don't
care about the actual function what it
is and machine learning model will map
find that function but I know this
structure and it finds additional
structural properties across other
attributes the interesting thing is this
for mammography you find severity of a
mass is your target attribute directly
from all these other features it finds
out margin and shape are the most
important ones in fact according to a
textbook in cancer medicine these are
the two most important features actually
medical doctors will rely on to give you
the severity of each case in terms of
directionality it's also interesting to
see that rods by rods is an artificial
assessment metric that doctors came up
with to classify the severity of
different patients so you would expect
that the actual severity should
determine that artificially made as a
my magic which is exactly what our model
says here severity determines violence
so in terms of directionality this type
of modeling can give you a bunch of
interesting intuition as to what is
happening in your data so this is the
type of structure that our models are
picking up and interestingly if I have
an entry there that there is some
structure based on this profiling
mechanism automated cleaning actually
will work very very well so if we take
that to split attributes across data
sets a bunch of different data sets as
they have a dependency based on the
model or they have no dependency we're
running imputation here so I cannot
reveal the name of that because it's
under review this is our
state-of-the-art technique for
imputation but we're also comparing it
against XE boost it can actually give
you insight as to when will automate it
imputation based on really
state-of-the-art machine learning models
will even work so if I have structure
you can see that I'm way more accurate
if I don't have structure I'm actually
not that accurate which is exactly an
instantiation of what our theory told us
does this answer your question on
structure I like I don't want to know
what the function is I cannot tell you
what the function is but I really want
to know if there is some deterministic
dependency the next step for this is
actually to apply to query optimization
and see if it can help find better
models for selectivity estimation and
all these things okay just to summarize
so what we we've done what I have been
doing in the last few years is really go
from theory around this type of new
noisy channel model for explaining how
errors are injected in real data to
building actually systems that map that
learn parts of this process and I can
you know holo-detector tell you what is
the noisy channel model to identify
errors hollow clean can
you what are and you know what should be
the real generating distribution of the
clean data auto if they gives you a
profile of that and so on and so forth
so we have this formal model and
basically we're building systems data
cleaning systems over over this they
just to mention one connection and I can
talk about it offline
it actually has exciting connections to
robust machine learning using exactly
this approach and the notion of
structure we have results that will be
soon under submission that many of the
state-of-the-art techniques that rely on
robust mean estimation and robust quartz
estimations actually and just removing
samples from when you're training a
model can be improved if you're worth
trying to correct a model so we have
that ready and also we have a system
that you can put as a filter in any
predictive pipeline and if there is a
noisy data set will always give you a
guarantee that you will get either the
same performance by running if you were
to run a machine learning model
downstream you'll either get the same
performance as if you were not to
perform any cleaning or if there is an
abstract or you'll always be better okay
so with that I'd like to thank you for
for attending and not be happy to answer
any questions that you have around this
the systems yes machine learning people
are so used to the fact that there's
gonna be you knows in the features there
is going to be noise into labels
I kind of have built this models
thinking about that you know
now say we repaired the data the
real-world data is still going to come
with noise yes and do you kind of
recommend repairing the test data as
well like the real world thing as well
and repairing the model in a way that it
now thinks about India we don't what I
recommend and what I recommend I cannot
recommend anything there but I
what I've seen happening especially in
the experiments that we have in the
deployments and in some some companies
you don't say into the model you want
your model to behavior bust two
different types of noise because that
introduces regularization and introduces
all these interesting properties that
you don't want to lose what you want is
a filter to avoid catastrophic basically
future changes so for so just to give
you an analogy with training let's focus
on training first and then I'll tell you
about test deployment for training what
people have done and what people have
been striving for and like even even now
it's like let me build a mechanism that
I will detect a weird an anomaly that is
not easy to detect and remove the
training point what if that training
point if it is a multi attribute field
is actually wrong just because of one
attribute that you can actually fix
because you have enough redundancy in
your data which would make it easier to
detect so if you can do that with
guarantees you actually increase the
sample that of clean points that you
have in your model will learn better so
you don't want you want to be a little
bit do dishes as to how you're throwing
and filtering data away that's the only
change that we are proposing based on
these results so when you're doing
training just instead of just throwing
away data try to fix centers in fact we
we are I'm working you know crystals
almost probably so we're working
together to show that actually you can
get much better guarantees and in the
case of contaminated statistics and in
the case of like robust estimators if
you perform that decoding basically it
has connections with with coding theory
again I can tell you about for
deployment
what we want is so you can detect that
there is noise in your input data that
you're feeding into a machine learning
model and turn off the pipeline right so
you have down service so your your
services go down your recommendations go
down or you're willing to take a hit and
survive with whatever recommendations
have gone haywire
if I have trained a cleaning model or a
filter that not only can tell me this is
wrong hence stop versus this is wrong
and I think I can fix it
and you put it as a very thin filter
before feeding the data into the
predictive model you can actually solve
that you will get you know you will
basically have your services run be
running and you don't have the answer
down time so what we are doing with this
is if I have a model that can fix things
and I have learned it as long as the
distributions don't sift and Saints
rapidly then you can use it in
production as a filtering mechanism to
basically recover the equivalent would
be really error correcting codes it's
exactly it there is a very strong
connection there so if I have if I know
that I can decode given the types of
noise I have if I know that I can decode
the efficiently I should decode and
recover the signal and run if I cannot
do it or if I cannot decode with
guarantees out but I can detect that
something is wrong there are two
different actions I can take if I can
detect something is wrong maybe I give
you a red flag otherwise I don't
intervene with with anything and it's
somebody else's job not be automated
system stuff so that's how I see there
the world with respect to robust time
and specifically people and humans in
the same time fully automated are should
human developer because Annette King
motors Ted
nobody trusts any fully-automated let me
say that what do you want though is you
want to prioritize how the cases that
they are looking at until they you
convince them at whatever the model is
saying is actually correct just to give
you some anecdotal evidence from
deployments of our systems there is this
company that was doing basically
categorization so they wanted to find a
canonical representation of things and
they had manual ground truth so they
gave us the ground truth they told us
compare learning model it took them like
months to create that it took us ten
hours to actually train something and be
able to deploy the money and we got an
accuracy of ninety seven percent based
on their ground the ground truth of the
three percent that we were in
disagreement 70 percent turns out it was
actually the ground truth was wrong our
system was correct because this system
they have a more holistic view of what
is happening in the data than humans you
will never convince somebody to trust
that though but what you can do is that
if the model now super confident about
something you can actually provide
surface that to the user with evidence
as to why the model is super confident
and that is a problem we haven't touched
at all until now it's connects to
provenance and clustering examples and
so on and so forth
it's the speed
[Applause]